let us now discuss a little bit the
simplest estimation problem that there
is the problem of estimating the mean of
a certain probability distribution and
we will take this occasion to introduce
some additional terminology and discuss
some desirable properties of estimators
so the context is as follows we have n
random variables that are independent
and they're identically distributed they
are drawn from some distribution that
has a certain mean theta and some
variance we assume that we do not know
the value of the mean and we want to
estimate it the most natural way of
estimating the mean is to form the
sample mean that is we take the n
observations and take their average
notice that this quantity the sample
mean or in this case it is the estimator
that we're using is a random variable
because its value is determined by the
values of the random variables X 1 up to
X n let us discuss some properties of
this estimator the first property is
that the expected value of this
estimator is equal to the true mean this
is because the expected value of each
one of the X's is Theta and therefore
the expected value of this ratio is
theta as well now this is a relation
that's true for all possible values of
theta let us appreciate the content of
this statement let us think what this
expectation actually is more generally
suppose that you were dealing with some
estimator which is some function of the
data then the expected value of this
estimator is using the expected value
rule and the zooming that we are dealing
with discrete random variable X the
expected value of theta hat is
determined as follows and so we see that
the expected value of our estimator
depends or
is affected by what the true value of
theta is so this is a quantity that
generally depends on theta and what we
want in order to have a so-called
unbiased estimator is that no matter
what theta is this expectation evaluates
to the true unknown value equal to theta
in general having this property having
an unbiased estimator is a desirable one
we do not want our estimates to be
systematically high or systematically
low no matter what the true value of
theta is a second property of the sample
mean estimator is the following by the
weak law of large numbers we know that
the sample mean converges to the true
mean in the sense of convergence in
probability once more this is a property
that's true no matter what the
underlying unknown value little theta is
when this is true this convergence is
true for all values of little theta then
we say that our estimator is consistent
or that we have consistency having a
consistent estimator is definitely a
very desirable property we would like
when we obtain more and more data that
our estimator will give us the correct
value finally we would like to say
something about the size of the
estimation error this is measured one
way of measuring it but which is the
most common it's measured in terms of
the mean squared error so theta is the
unknown value this is our estimator this
is the error we square the error and we
take the average what we've got here for
the specific example of the sample mean
estimator is the following since it is
unbiased we have a random variable minus
the mean of that random variable so this
is just the variance of the estimator
and for the sample mean we know that
it's variance is Sigma squared over N so
this gives us some very specific
knowledge about how the mean squared
error behaves as we change n in this
particular example the mean squared
error did not depend on theta it's the
same no matter what the truth eita
is but in other situations and with
other estimators you might actually
obtain here a function of theta